I was watching Zuckerberg testimony
yesterday and again today and I was
noticing yesterday especially he was
asked a lot about Facebook's Terms of
Service yeah those are the terms you
agreed to when you use Facebook and it
seemed to be all anyone during those
hearings was talking about have you seen
these Terms of Service before actually
at the first line of our Terms of
Service the Terms of Service Terms of
Service Terms of Service Terms of
Service Terms of Service Terms of
Service the Terms of Service Terms of
Service the Terms of Service the terms
of the what do you call it the Terms of
Service Zuckerberg said he thought most
users didn't read Facebook's Terms of
Service page thoroughly and so I started
poking around last night to investigate
it turns out a lot of apps out there and
a lot of websites have Terms of Service
that users may not be aware they've
agreed to check it out for example ways
the app that helps you avoid traffic
when you click agree on ways you agree
not to take legal action when we steer
you into the middle of a street gang
firefight that's what it says
unbelievable yeah Netflix Netflix when
you click agree on Netflix you agree to
make people feel bad for not watching
bloodline yes
uber uber when you click agree on uber
you agree to show up to an important
event in a Scion pumping turkish house
music yeah tinder when you click agree
on tinder you agree to use that photo of
yourself taken eight years ago right
after you had stomach flu that's a
promise the playboy app the playboy app
when you click agree on playboy you
agree that you were recently unfrozen
after being in case in a glacier for 25
years this is the first time you've used
the internet so you were not aware of
anywhere else you could possibly find
online pornography
the New York City subway Maps app yeah
when you click agree on the New York
City subway Maps app you agree to watch
two rats fight over a human thumb weed
maps an app that will help you find a
weed dispensary near you when you click
agree on weed maps you agree to have a
roommate well into your 50 and finally
Dunkin Donuts app when you click agree
on the Dunkin Donuts app you agree to go
[Applause]
you